-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night".
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
President Biden is said to have
his annual physical
later this month.
Well, at least that's one probe
that won't turn up
any documents.
[ Laughter ]
God willing.
The FBI reportedly searched
President Biden's
Delaware beach house today
as part of the ongoing
investigation
into his handling
of classified documents.
And I think he might
be getting nervous,
because he said, "You know what
you should be searching?
Hunter's laptop.
Crazy stuff in there."
[ Laughter ]
Democratic Congressman
Jamie Raskin asked
the Secret Service yesterday
to turn over visitor logs
to Mar-a-Lago and former
Vice President Mike Pence's
Indiana home.
Let me save you the time --
Domino's guy and no one.
[ Laughter ]
The Biden administration
proposed new rules today
that would limit
credit card company fees
for missed payments.
"Oh, I never charge anything,"
said Merrick Garland.
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience murmurs ]
[ Groans ]
According to a new poll,
15% of voters said
that the most important problem
facing the county's inflation --
oh, wait, now it's 20%?
Oh, God, now it's 25-- 30%?
Oh, my God, you know what?
I'm gonna stop looking.
I'm gonna just stop looking.
Authorities in Texas
yesterday located
the two emperor tamarin monkeys
that went from the Dallas Zoo
inside the closet
of an abandoned home.
And they left them there because
at this point,
that's a more secure location
than the Dallas Zoo.
[ Laughter ]
Tomorrow is groundhog day,
which is weird,
'cause we still haven't had
the first six weeks of winter.
[ Laughter ]
According to new analysis,
the price of beef is expected
to increase this year by 15%,
so it's gonna be weird
when the price
of a Quarter Pounder doesn't.
[ Laughter ]
Then what is it?
And finally, the candy executive
who's credited
as the father of Peeps, for
creating the marshmallow treat,
died recently at the age of 98.
And his last words were, "Please
don't let them call me
the father of Peeps."
[ Laughter ]
That was a monologue, everybody.